pour la première fois la france
participera demain à une journée
internationale des enfants disparus
à titre exceptionnel et pour l'occasion
nous avons décidé de recueillir à sa
demande
l'appel du père d'estelle qui s'adresse
aux ravisseurs malgré tous les efforts
entrepris par les enquêteurs aucune
piste n'est aucune nouvelle à ce jour de
la fillette de 9 ans disparu depuis le 9
janvier 2003 amaury guibert bernie
mériaux il se décrit lui même comme un
acharné eric mouzin le père d'estelle se
rend tous les quinze jours à la police
judiciaire de versailles là une cellule
de 9 enquêteurs s'occupe exclusivement
de sa fille
je pense que pour l' enquête pour le
groupe et ce temps c'est la même chose
que pour nous c'est un défi et un défi
c'est fait pour être gagné
la native depuis la disparition
d'estelle le 9 janvier tout a été tenté
affiches géantes création d'une
association et d'un site internet
eric mouzin est même devenu une figure
de la télévision
ce jour-là il participe à une émission
sur les enfants disparus
pour lutter contre l'oubli pour susciter
un témoignage qui relancera l'anc est
depuis cet hiver les recherches
piétinent malgré des moyens
exceptionnels tout le village de
guermantes a été perquisitionné en vain
la thèse de l'enlèvement est privilégiée
mais les pistes manque alors le père
d'estelle nous a contactés renouvelle
son appel à d'éventuels ravisseurs
j'ignore qui vous êtes et où vous vous
trouvez je suis en revanche certain que
vous m'entendez et que vous en sentez
flatté
estelle n'est pas une chose que l'on
peut garder comme cela est elle est une
enfant qui doit retrouver sa liberté et
sa famille quand il ait pu arriver à
estelle vous devez nous la rendre il n'y
a pas dans ce message de marchandage ni
d'appel à quelque forme d'humanité qui
pourrait être en vous vous avez commis
un acte monstrueux et vous ne faites pas
partie du genre humain
je ne suis pas un justicier je suis
simplement un père qui veut retrouver sa
fille
les suites qui seront données à cette
affaire par la justice ne m'intéresse
pas aujourd'hui
mais n'espérez pas l'impunité en france
il y à chaque année en moyenne une
disparition d'enfant qui reste
inexpliquée